strawberries with balsamic vinegar I  know that you think chocolate is the way  to go but I'm telling you it's balsamic  all the way it's so good despite being  lactose intolerant I love cheese Vermont  cloth bound cheddar cheese with  pistachio butter Yes you heard it right  so you have like the salty creaminess  and the sweetness of the pistachio  butter is so good with cheddar  you don't even need a cracker so good I  did not take my Lactaid  mangoes delicious sweet creamy juicy  what they need is a little bit of salt  and a little bit of heat and a little  bit of acid in the form of tahin I love  this stuff so much but this is one of my  very favorite Mexican street food snacks  it's my favorite it like wakes you up  better than caffeine  this is so good  oh we got the chili powder in there try  some of these please get curious in the  kitchen see you next time